the holiday season it is here and a lot
of you are buying gifts for the people
and the pets in your life hopefully you
are and joining us now is pet trend
expert patrondologist charlotte reed
talk about where people are pet shopping
this year and i guess what they're
getting charlotte welcome back to the
program uh what should people be looking
at this year
well first of all i want to say happy
holidays as well as happy hanukkah
absolutely absolutely
well to answer your question you know
with shipping delays and just the covid
pandemic kind of moving along with the
new virus people really are shopping
online especially millennials they're
showing us the way you know they want
one-stop shopping to avoid any type of
problems and that's why i wanted to
feature chewy.com they've got seasonal
apparel like what the dogs are wearing
where it's a cute sweatshirt that says
melt for me coats
and fleeces from their exclusive frisco
collection as well as costumes but they
also have gift boxes for dogs and cats
as well as
dog and cat toys because we love our
cats especially some of the people at
the station so also you can find the
latest in pet tech products as you know
ces is upon us and a lot of pet parents
they want presents that's for both of
them so this way they can check in with
their pet and also give their pet a
treat while they're working or whether
away for the time being so you mentioned
chewy i know that's a popular site for a
lot of pet owners but you know it's it's
hard to get an idea from your dogs and
cats and what they enjoy they tend not
to respond clearly in english when you
ask them that question so what should
maybe pet owners look for specifically
what are some new cool things that their
pets could enjoy this year
well like i said the furbook hammer is
really cool kind of this pet site
exercise wheel actually what i like
about it is for dogs and cats because
they're so overweight you put the treats
in and it goes on so those dogs and cats
that need a little exercise the treat
pops right out here they can run around
the house it's not necessarily you know
the camera where you can check it and
see what's going on in your home but you
could also get your pet moving around
working for that tree you've got great
toys some of these are seasonal then
you've got uh you know little cat toys a
little filled with catnip so those are
really important also for pet parents
there's a great selection of whether
it's jumpers or sweaters or matching
pajamas for you and your dog and cat as
well as a wide selection of ornaments i
mean people love shopping online it's
and of course they shop at chewy.com
like i said it's one stop shopping but
there's amazon there's all sorts of
sites that they can shop on including
their favorite pet store site um so
there's a lot of shopping out there to
do i just think this is kind of a hipper
site you can do one-stop shopping but
you know the other things that people
really like this time of the year are
treats because as you know dogs and cats
are absolute foodies so i brought this
gift basket we usually tend to see
treats in stockings like stocking
stuffers which we'll still probably do
but i love this selection of treats
because not only is it treats of all
kinds and all shapes for dogs that are a
little older they can have soft
jerky treats or whether you have a big
chewer or even if you have a puppy or
whether you're going to be traveling you
need a long lasting boat but it's also
got your dining accessories this is the
wolf day basket by loving pets and for
dogs on the go there's even a travel
ball to go as well as mats and as well
as placemats you can keep that floor
nice and wet and we all know
dogs and cats like to chow down without
a doubt yes they do especially when
they're getting all these cool new
treats and cool new gift baskets
charlotte just thank you for giving us a
little bit of a flavor of what we can
get our pets this holiday season we
appreciate it and thanks for joining us
this morning
thank you